- Oh gosh!
I wish you could feel
the energy in this room,
maybe you can.
I have had so much fun
with all of you guys today.
Let's kick it over to our
virtual friends and family,
our VFFs, maybe someone's
got a question for me.
I hear a Jessica does.
(Drew gasps)
- Hey, hey Drew!
- Hey Jessica, oh look at your little one!
- I know, he's cozy this morning
and that's our question,
so we like to be cozy,
it's Fall in Ohio, I like
to have the windows open
with the breeze and blankets
but my husband would rather
just turn on the heat,
so he can be more comfortable
and not be so chilly.
How can you help us
with the thermostat war?
- Well, maybe instead
of the thermostat war
'cause I love Ohio and you
guys have a range of weathers,
maybe you guys could blanket
and cozy and extra PJs
and sort of do
a fabric-ed version of a sleep
number situation, you know?
- I like that.
- You can strip down and he can bundle up
and then you guys can sort of meet
in that pretty little middle
but I feel your dilemma.
Look, they've made
mattresses two different ways
because people do have
different preferences
and that's okay but I can
actually sidebar with you
and talk about accoutrements and outfits
and things to help with.
(applause)
- Well I appreciate the advice.
- Thank you Jessica, thank you,
thank you for your question.
You know what?
I think there might be another
Jessica who has a question.
Two, two, two Jessicas!
Jessica, are you there?
Hello?
Oh, she's on her way?
Oh from Vancouver!
- Yes!
- I love Canada!
- Yay!
- What's your question?
- Yes I've got a question.
I get seasonal dry lips, do
you have a remedy for that?
- I am so glad you asked
because my dermatologist,
who's renowned and incredible
and we can all benefit from her wisdom,
Dr Dan's Cortibalm.
I had never heard about this product,
it completely changed my life
and it will change yours,
we'll have it on the
website in Drew's Picks,
I think that's the section so,
but I am gonna personally
send you some, Jessica.
Thank you everyone, love you VFFs!
(upbeat music)